let's face it between english classes
lit classes world culture classes and
history classes
there is no escaping the epic poem
the odyssey the iliad the enid
the epic of gilgamesh the beowulf
at some point we're going to have to
confront the lyrical beauty of
big strong men and big strong armor
fighting big
strong monsters and saving their
kingdoms and loving on their ladies or
loving on their male best friend but
that's a different poem
[Music]
today we're going to take a look at one
particular epic poem
and follow its long winding journey from
way
way way long ago all the way to the
present day
and will interrogate its relevance to
our lives in the here
and now so come on gaetz and danes
to the violent bloody mythic mysterious
world
of beowulf to see beowulf's malleability
in action look no further than the very
first word of the poem
beowulf has a sort of once upon a time
structure where the narrator is telling
us a tale how lovely he has to get our
attention
somehow so he starts off by exclaiming
what which is little john the narrator
of beowulf
because if so would listen to the
audiobook
a lot of older versions use stuffier
translations like
low or park but you gotta party like
it's 1999.
so sheamus haney begins his translation
with
so it's friday afternoon your lit
teacher assigns you a five page
book report due monday on jimmy
squibble's
most recent magnum opus hype house
bloodbath mwah love it and you start
with the basics
hype house bloodbath by jimmy squibbles
author okay check some historical
context now
written at jimmy's salton c lake house
in the summer of 2018
check you know this book report ain't so
hard after all i wonder why they didn't
do it in the final season of game of
thrones
but that's a different story okay
hotshot now try that with
beowulf beowulf written
in when was beowulf written anyway
okay let's try a softball who
wrote beowulf
wait was beowulf even written
at all hey siri
who wrote beowulf
nothing while scholars agree on all
things hype house bloodbath and how
could they not it's such a tightly
written piece of work
they really don't agree much when it
comes to beowulf
except for one thing the plot the meat
pagan scandinavia 6th century king
rothgar's meat hall
mead is an alcohol made with fermented
honey and a meat hall is a big building
with
one big room where you guessed it much
meat is enjoyed rowdy places these meat
halls
very rowdy rothgar is king of the danes
a northern germanic tribe in southern
scandinavia
an area that today includes denmark
proper
and scanland which is the southern tip
of the scandinavian peninsula
one night a monster named grendel comes
to crash rothgar's meat hall festivities
and ends up killing most of rothgar's
men not cool that's why you were invited
grendel
enter beowulf a mighty warrior charged
with killing grendel
beowulf is a gayat another north
germanic tribe that resides in the land
of the
geots and beowulf does what anyone would
do before they fight a
fearsome monster he gets into his
birthday suit
at least according to some translations
sometimes he has weapons but
we're gonna have him be naked for this
one because the way beowulf sees it if
grendel doesn't have
weapons and armor why should he
couldn't be me but okay beowulf slays
grendel and there is much celebration
and even more mead
yay but then grendel's mama is having
none of that because
beowulf killed her boy y'all she's like
look how they massacred my boy
i want him dead i want all of his men
dead
so she attacks rothgar's meat hall
beowulf
kills her and there is much celebration
and so
much mead that i'm honestly concerned
for their liver what was the life
expendency for gayats and danes
anyway beowulf bids rothgar and his
danes farewell and returns home to
gayotland and becomes king of the gayats
50 years go by then one day boom a
dragon attacks
it happens to the best of us by this
time beowulf is
old and he isn't as spry as he once was
plus
it's a dragon i feel like this is a job
for that hiccup kid like he trains
dragons beowulf defeats the dragon i
mean this
is beowulf we're talking about but not
before the dragon mortally wounds him
beowulf's body is cremated rest in power
a tower is built in his honor and i
assume
much mead is also had beowulf the mighty
warrior will live on in our memories
and his legend will be told for
generations
hence this video now how that story is
told is up for much debate
here's the opening line of seamus
heaney's introduction to his 1999
translation of beowulf
the poem called beowulf was composed
sometime
between the middle of the seventh and
the end of the 10th century of the first
millennium
in the language that is today called
anglo-saxon
or old english right off the bat we're
dealing with a window of
300 plus years as to when beowulf could
have been composed
that's like comparing today to 1821.
we were only five us presidents deep in
by then
and to further complicate matters we
don't even know what form of composition
that took
it very well could have begun as a story
passed down through our old tradition
perpetually evolving and changing only
to then be later written down
this oral tradition theory opens up a
whole can of worms for scholars
and is you guessed it up for much debate
see if beowulf began as a story told
around the campfire
it would be nearly impossible to trace
it back to a so-called
author because it probably wouldn't even
have one
detractors of the oral tradition theory
cite a number of issues
not the least of which is the sheer
complexity of beowulf
to them the sophisticated language
structure and themes are so
complex that had they somehow been
verbally passed down
they would have had a nearly impossible
chance of surviving
the messy game of telephone that is oral
tradition
regardless of how baof came to be
written down we do
have a manuscript says translator seamus
heaney
we know about the poem more or less by
chance because it exists in one
manuscript only and boy oh boy is she a
scrappy survivor
barely making it through a fire in the
18th century
our dating for the manuscript is between
9 75
and 10 25 a window of only 50 years
which for beowulf is like a dang
bullseye
and whatever mysteries already
surrounded beowulf they ballooned
exponentially
when the text was then transcribed and
titled
re-transcribed and edited translated
and adapted interpreted and
reinterpreted until it had become
canonical fanfic writers you know how it
is
and even though beowulf is fantastical
as all get out
it is deeply interwoven with real life
elements
that not only muddy the waters as to
what aspects of beowulf are historical
but also give some levity to some of the
more outrageous stuff
these historical figures
clans and events
certainly make it tough to untangle the
historical
from the fantastical all this talk of
monsters and
dragons and the use of historical
elements as a way to lend believability
to fantasy
guess it's only another time before we
talk about the man himself
j.r.r tolkien beowulf was a huge
influence on tolkien and his work so
much so that he is widely regarded as
the man
responsible for kick-starting modern
criticism of beowulf
tolkien's argument was that scholars had
been so wrapped up
in the historicity of beowulf that they
were neglecting its value as a piece of
literature
in his 1936 lecture beowulf the monsters
and the critics
tolking noted that beowulf is in fact so
interesting as poetry and places poetry
are so powerful
that this quite overshadows the
historical content
indeed the allure of beowulf is so
powerful that it can transform a
bored student into a bonafide translator
maria davonna hedley whose vibrant 2020
translation of beowulf views the poem
and its characters through a modern lens
admits that
even she didn't really take to beowulf
at first
after reading an old translation
pre-shame pre-sheamus heaney's 1999
version she reflected
i'm not gonna lie to you i read it and i
thought
all of the elements are here for this to
be thrilling
and instead it feels just kind of flat
hadley's experience with beowulf is a
prime example of the now
self-perpetuating legacy of the poem
it's been studied and translated so
often that younger generations continue
to discover new ways of connecting
with the material while the poem has
been translated into 38 other languages
the number of translations and
adaptations varies
true beowulf style we can't even agree
on the number of translations
in british academic and the orchards
2003
a critical companion to beowulf he cites
33
representative translations in his
bibliography
also in 2003 an annotated list from the
arizona center for medieval and
renaissance studies
cites more than 300 translations and
adaptations
the beowulf afterlives bibliographic
database online
lists an ever-growing number of
translations and adaptations
and as of the time of this recording the
numbers at 740
744 great beowulf is so popular that i'm
745 going to have to remake this very
video
every month aren't i beowulf is the gift
that keeps on giving
continually evolving as each of us bring
our own experiences to it
we change the text and the text changes
us beowulf scholar chris jones likens
beowulf to other poems which
move through time being kept alive by
readings
misreadings reimaginings and occurring
stories and significance around
themselves as they go
they are stories as well as telling
stories
beowulf he says is not an object fixed
in the past
even if we never ever ever find out
anything more about beowulf who wrote it
where it came from when it came from we
still have beowulf
so of course historical context matters
cultural context matters religious
context matters
but it's not everything there is clearly
something accessible here for audiences
especially when you break it down to
cool dude fights monsters
i mean that's basically anime which
means don't be scared of beowulf yes
it's old
like your grandma but it's precisely
because of its oldness that it's so
incredibly fascinating
again like your grandma it's been
studied to death and yet its origins
still remain so mysterious
and because it's so old its influence
over the stories we read
watch and tell today is so deeply rooted
that we've all already experienced
beowulf and its legacy
whether we know it or not so let's raise
a glass to king beowulf slayer of
dragons
monsters and the monsters moms
whoever gets in his way it's the end
i'm done